Sarah Chen: Alright, let's get started. Marcus, you're up first.
Marcus Johnson: Yesterday I wrapped up parts of the backend event pipeline (issue #59 Backend Event Pipeline). Tests passed in staging. Today I'll start the event fanout work (issue #69 Implement latency query API endpoints) and my blocker is a rate-limiter design question.
Priya Patel: I'm working on the Frontend Notification UI (issue #60 Frontend Notification UI). WIP — the basic flow is in place but the badge count isn't updating in real time; might need Marcus's help once the fanout piece lands.
David Kim: QA tested the token bucket limiter (issue #96 Implement token bucket rate limiter in Redis) and found an edge case around timezones causing flaky test failures. I'm pairing with Marcus to reproduce.
Alex Rivera: I'm focusing on notifications infra — building the WebSocket API (issue #263 Build WebSocket API) and device sync (issue #264 Integrate Device Sync). Blocked on auth endpoint from API team (issue #77 [GTM] Changelog draft — EU Payment Methods is unrelated but I need the auth dependency).
Jordan Taylor: Design review kicked off for the Notification Settings Panel (issue #262 Add Notification Settings Panel). Two of four screens are done; feedback due Thursday.
Priya Patel: Delivery confidence — I expect the notification UI to be shippable next week if the fanout and websocket pieces are unblocked. Remaining uncertainty: the token-bucket limiter behaviour under DST transitions.
Sarah Chen: Decision needed — do we prioritize shipping WebSockets now or fall back to a short polling strategy for the dashboard? After a quick discussion, we decided to prioritize WebSockets for v1 of Real-Time Notifications to reduce complexity later.
Marcus Johnson: Quality risk — we noticed missing integration tests for device sync. I'll add tests this week. Cross-team coordination: Marcus will pair with Alex on the auth contract once API provides the endpoint.
David Kim: Blockers & dependencies — QA needs a stable staging environment with the new rate-limiter in place to finish regression testing. I'll file follow-ups if needed.
END